girls who build is an outreach effort
focused on getting high school girls
excited about science and engineering we
hold hands on workshops where girls
learn from industry experts and
experiment with technologies like
wearable electronics and robotics for
our latest workshop 40 girls came to
that MIT Lincoln Laboratory ever work
center to learn all about cameras we
wanted to show the girls how optics
sensors and image processing combine to
make apps they use everyday like
Instagram work I got to see like how
filters work and how they're like made
and how I can be
the girls tore apart while digital and
film cameras to see how they're made
then they built their own cameras using
a raspberry pi computer in camera module
others just cool how we had to like make
the camera put the different parts
together like it made everything a lot
more clear about how normal cameras work
the girls heard from speakers who talked
about how cameras are used in fields as
diverse as searching for exoplanets
underwater Salvage improving cancer
treatment and 3d tomography my favorite
part of the day was listen to all the
keynote speakers is they were all so
passionate about what their field were
but it all connected to one core idea of
like the camera technology
I started girls who build because I am a
female engineer who didn't grow up
fixing cars with my dad I had no
previous exposure to power tools
circuits or programming before college
it's my vision that when girls enter
college they have the same hands-on
engineering background as their peers I
want them to realize they can use power
tools code and solder to the issue isn't
an ability or intelligence but just a
lack of exposure to these things I would
like girls to discover the amazing power
of engineering even before they apply to
college I was definitely thinking about
like computer science it's like a good
question
so I thought this is like a super cool
way to get like more experience out of
that before I went off to college
whoa
you
you